before we move on i just want to make
sure you have a deep understanding of
how we actually computed
600
whoops that's not what i wanted to do
600
why is my pen malfunctioning let's see
698
no that's not the word boy my
not only is my pen malfunctioning my
brain is as well 686
minus 298
and i drew out the place values and
everything last time but i want to show
you that you don't have to do that but
you can still have the exact same
intuition
so the way you should do this type of
problem in a few videos we're going to
start doing this with four digit numbers
and that's why i want to make sure you
have you understand it properly with
three digit numbers
is you
you know the way i did last time i said
oh well you know first i have to
subtract in the ones place and i have an
eight here and six years so let me get
some tens from the tens place and then i
you know this became but what i want to
show you is you can actually do all of
the regrouping or all of the borrowing
depending on how you want to call it
although i like to call it taking ahead
of time rather than borrowing because
you don't give it back so how do we
think about it so in order to do any
subtraction problem you just have to
make sure that the number on top is
bigger than the number on the bottom
right so for example in the hundreds
place here and we're not going to
negative numbers yet just yet well
you'll learn that in a couple of years
or if you're especially advanced maybe
even faster but
we see here that in the hundreds place
this number is lower than this number so
that's cool
but then when we go to the tens place
what happens here this nine which
represents 90 that's bigger than this 8
which represents 80 right so how can we
subtract 90 from 80 and you'll learn
later that'll give you a negative number
and all of that but we want to stay in
positive numbers so we have to have a
number larger than 90 here and we only
have 80 here we only have 8 tens
so what we can do
is we have 600 right here right this 6
represents 6 hundreds so let's take one
of them
so we'll take
so we'll take one of the six hundreds
and we're left with just five hundreds
but now we have a hundred to play with
and let's put those hundreds in the tens
place
well a hundred is how many
tens a hundred is ten tens right
so if we add a hundred to eighty
we get what we get a hundred and eighty
but if we write that as
tens that's eighteen tens
so this becomes
eighteen tens
right let me and i really want you to
understand i don't want to just do this
mechanically i really want you to
understand what's going on here
when we took when we took this six and
turned into a five we took one from the
hundreds place
one from the hundreds place represents
one hundred so when you take that
hundred and represent it in the tens
place it becomes ten tens right one
hundred is ten tens
so we have eight tens and we add ten
tens to it so then you get eighteen tens
right that one
all i'm saying is that 100
becomes
10
tens
right 10 times 10 is 100. and we added
those 10 tenths to the 8 tens that we
already had here we got 18. so now the 5
is greater than the 2 500 is greater
than 200
18 tens or 180 is greater than 9 tens or
90.
but then here we have 6
is smaller than 8 so we're not done yet
so what can we do how can we add more
ones here well we could take a 10 from
here we could take a 10 from here and
then
and then put it into the ones place so
let's take a 10 away so we're going to
take a 10 here
so we only have 17 tens left right
because this is the tens place
so 110
is equal to right you can almost use a
10 bill right we had 18 10 bills now we
took one of those 10 bills and we had 17
and so that equals one and that equals
ten ones
right a ten dollar bill is equal to ten
one dollar bills and so we took one ten
from here and then we could put it into
the ones place
so we have ten more ones so then this
becomes well we had six or so you know
we could say six dollars and now we're
going to add 10 to it so we're going to
add 16.
you may have learned you know before
that you're taking a 1 and you can put
the 1 to the 8. but why is that really
happening because you took a 1 from here
but that 1
is 100 which represents 10 ones
sorry that one is 100 so it represents
10 tens so 10 10 plus 8 times was 18
tens
and then similarly we took a 10 from
here
and so we have 17 tens
and then and then we took that one ten
turn it into ten ones and added to the
six i'm probably confusing you but
hopefully you're getting the intuition
so now we're in a situation where the
five is greater than the two the
seventeen is greater than the nine and
the sixteen is greater than the 8 and so
we're ready to subtract and we can do it
in any direction we want to we could
start from the left and go to the right
we could start from the right and go to
the left
let's i don't know since it's a little
unconventional start from the left
what's 500 minus 200
what's 300 right because we're in the
hundreds place
what's 17 tens minus 9 10. so that's the
same thing as 170
minus 90.
right well that's 80 or 8 tens
well you could say 17 minus 9 is 8.
and then finally what is 16 minus 8 well
that's just 8.
so there you have it that was the
problem we just did and hopefully that
clarified things a little bit
so let's move to the next problem
so problem number five on the same page
is taking me 20 minutes just to stay on
the same page a man
an unnamed man that's kind of suspicious
a man
sold
230
balloons
balloons
at a carnival in the morning
that's kind of
that's kind of unimportant information
we don't have to know that it was at a
carnival in the morning that's just
there to confuse you so i'm just going
to write that a man sold 230 balloons
and i don't care where he sold it or
what time he sold it he then says he
sold
he sold
another
86 balloons in the evening once again i
don't care what i'll say and so this was
in the morning
in evening
the question they ask us is
how many balloons did he sell in all how
many
did
he sell
in
all well if you sold 200 let's say in
the morning which i didn't write down
but let's let's say that this is you
know man sold 230 balloons in the
morning so that's that part of the
statement
so we could represent it with the
singapore math bars that they like to do
so let's say that that's that has length
of 230
and the units here are balloons
maybe that should be another unit of
length the balloon
that's 230 and then it says he sold
another 86 in the evening
he sold sold another 86 in the evening
so let's use one of these singapore math
bars
so he sold another 86
maybe it looks something like that
so he sold another 86 in the evening
and they want to know how many did he
sell in all so how many did he sell in
all
let me pick a new color
how many did he sell in all what's going
to be this number that he sold in the
morning plus the number he sold in the
evening
it's going to be this whole length so
it's essentially going to be the sum
of 230 and 86.
so 230 and 86 is the total number of
balloons he sold so 230
plus
86
230 plus 86 that 8 should be right below
the 3. so okay let's add the ones place
so 0 plus 6 so that's 6 ones
right zero ones plus six ones is six
ones
so three tens plus eight tens right
because we're in the tens place
that equals 11 tens
right
but 11 tens we can't write it we can't
write 11 right here in the tens place
so what we do is so you know this 3 this
3 plus 8 that's the same thing as 30
plus 80 right because we're in the 10th
place
and we know 30 plus 80 you know that
equals 11 times equals 110
but we can't write a hundred we can't
write 11 here 11 is not a digit so what
we could do is we could take a hundred
of this
and turn it and and and turn it into one
so this is you could read it as a
hundred
plus ten right
or you could view it one in the hundreds
place and a ten so what we can do is
let's just put the one
ten down here
and then the hundreds place and you
might have learned this is you know
carry the one
put it up here right kind of you know
when i was learning math and elementary
school they would say oh three plus
eight is eleven so put the one down
carry the one but essentially what
you're doing you're saying thirty plus
eighty is a 110 and 110 is 100 and 110
so we're putting the 10 down here
because that's the tens place and then
the 100 we're adding to the hundreds
place so that's what carrying the one
really is and i want you to have that
intuition although you know if you just
said carry the one it's really easy
three plus eight is eleven carry the one
and now we have a one in the hundreds
place this is a hundred plus a two
hundred that equals three hundred
so three hundred sixteen that's how many
balloons the unnamed man sold in all at
the carnival i will see you in the next
video